in this video we'll try to understand
the basic idea behind normalizing flows
a technique used in machine learning to
build complex probability distributions
by transforming simple ones in
particular they've been applied in the
context of generative modeling and as
we'll see allow us to construct models
with some nice properties so we'll first
examine the basic mathematical framework
of normalizing flows and then we'll take
a look at an example paper that uses a
normalizing flow to learn a generative
model of images suppose we have a
continuous random variable Z with some
simple distribution like a spherical
Gaussian allowing for easy sampling and
density evaluation the key idea is to
transform this simple distribution with
some function f into a more complicated
one well formulate f as the composition
of a sequence of invertible
transformations so the overall
transformation is also invertible for
any X we have exactly one Z that could
have been sampled to produce it so say
we ask what the density is of a given X
we might think that we can just say okay
P of x equals P of F inverse of X well
in general no this isn't the case it
depends on the behavior of F so to
understand how this works we can take a
look at what's called the change of
variables formula when we have an
invertible and differentiable function f
mapping from some domain z to domain x
with the distribution P of Z defined
over domain Z the change of variables
formula says that P of X is actually
equal to P of F inverse of X multiplied
by the magnitude of the determinant of
the Jacobian of F inverse that is the
matrix of all first order partial
derivatives of F inverse so what does
this mean well first let's replace each
F inverse of X with unique Z associated
with X so we're mapping X to its inverse
e evaluating the density of this Z under
P of Z then multiplying by some scalar
magnitude now we know that a valid
probability density function must always
integrate
one over its domain the magnitude of the
Jacobian determinant which basically
indicates how much a transformation
locally expands or contracts space is
necessary to ensure that the new density
function P of X satisfies this
requirement let's look at an example
when Z and X are two dimensional the
Jacobian of F at a given point in Z
gives a linear approximation to how X is
instantaneously changing with Z so
imagine we have a square region of space
in Z near this point the partial
derivatives in the Jacobian locally
define how this region will be
transformed by F for example let's say
we have a 2 for each diagonal term and
zeros elsewhere locally this
transformation is stretching both
dimensions by a factor of 2 likewise
according to the determinant the area of
the initial square region should
increase by a factor of 4 now the change
of variables formula we had previously
contains the determinant of DZ the x the
determinant of the inverse Jacobian
which is actually just the reciprocal of
the determinant of the original Jacobian
and we know that the total probability
of the blue region in Z should be equal
to the total probability of its image
under F
what the change of variables formula is
saying is that in order for this to be
true locally each point in the X region
has to have 1/4 as much density as its
inverse now we don't actually care
whether the Jacobian preserves
orientation or not for example consider
the case where we replace the
bottom-right term in the Jacobian with
negative 2
we no longer preserve orientation as the
region and X flips upside down and the
Jacobian determinant is now negative 4
not positive 4 but we only care about
its magnitude the relationship between
the densities of points in X and points
in Z will be the same so we call our
sequence of by checked of
transformations and normalizing flow
after Z is initially sampled it flows
through the sequence with its density
function being renormalized at each step
to ensure it remains valid normalizing
flows have been used particularly and
work on generative models as you've
likely seen Gemma to modeling is all
about learning to approximate some
observed data distribution say of
natural images or speech audio and these
can be used to sample new data points
with similar characteristics to the
training data conditionally complete a
sample as an image in painting evaluate
probabilities or densities of samples
and see which samples are more likely or
infer latent variables that allow us to
reduce the dimensionality of the data or
expose interval structure that enables
generating samples with specific
characteristics one way to use
normalizing flows in a latent variable
generative model is to parameterize the
likelihood as a flow in our framework Z
will serve as a latent variable with
prior P of Z and X will be the observed
variable produced by passing Z through
the by jekt of transformation F so let's
derive our maximum likelihood objective
first we take the log of both sides
distributing the log through the product
on the right hand side now we know that
the overall transformation F was
specifically constructed to be the
composition of a sequence of functions
so this law determinate term can be
replaced with the sum of the log
determinant of each intermediate
Jacobian this setup will allow us to
directly train our model via maximum
likelihood as we can compute the log
marginal likelihood exactly
now this differs from some other
prominent deep generator models such as
variational auto-encoders known as V AES
and generative adversarial networks
known as Ganz in the VA II case we can
only approximate a lower bound on the
log likelihood known as the evidence
lower bound or elbow and this is what we
optimize during training in Ganz we
actually avoid evaluation of the
likelihood altogether and instead
optimize a minimax objective involving
the discriminator and the generator in
addition the flow based framework allows
for exact posterior inference in fact
the invert ability of F guarantees that
we can find the unique Z that generates
a given X with a Vee
we have an encoder network
parameterizing an approximate posterior
as computing the actual posterior is
intractable and in a standard can there
is no encoder for inferring the lanes
and the generator is not guaranteed to
have full support over the data now we
have the sequence of potentially high
dimensional by jected functions whose
Jacobian determinant we need to be able
to compute but this can get expensive
the basic trick often used is to ensure
that the Jacobian is triangular this is
because the determinant of a triangular
matrix is just the product of the
diagonal elements so we don't have to
take into account any of the off
diagonal elements for example in the
paper
nice nonlinear independent components
estimation the authors ensure that the
Jacobian of each transformation is
triangular via what are called coupling
layers let Z be the input to a coupling
layer we first partition Z into two
subsets for instance two contiguous sub
vectors
for the first subset we simply apply the
identity copying over the elements to
the same positions in the layers output
X to get the remaining portion of X we
use two functions n ng n takes us input
the first subset of Z and then the
output of N and the second subset of Z
serve as inputs for G we can look at the
Jacobian of this transformation because
elements in the first subset are not
affected by elements in the second we
end up with all zeros in the upper right
block and with the identity in the upper
left we'll just need to make sure that
the lower right block is lower
triangular to ensure that the full
Jacobian is triangular the lower left
block will have no restrictions because
elements in the first subset are left
unchanged by a coupling later we'll also
need to alternate roles between the two
subsets as we compose multiple coupling
layers together as for inverting this
transformation well we can of course
invert the identity portion but what
about the second part this G function
well basically G is just required to be
invertible with respect to its first
argument and given the second since we
contribute its second argument in the
paper nice G is kept simple and just
returns the sum of its two arguments to
form an additive coupling later recent
papers have a bit more sophisticated
transformations but the basic idea is
the same so no matter how complex the
function n is say it's a deep neural
network the overall transformation is
still easily invertible and it's
Jacobian determinant is simple to
compute in fact these additive coupling
layers have a unit Jacobian determinant
so they neither contract nor expand
space and even a composition of several
of these preserves volume but we
actually don't want this restricted
behavior the model should be able to
perform expansions and contractions at
different points in space to allow for
more flexibility when matching the data
distribution as we start with a simple
Gaussian we won't be able to model
multimodal distributions without this
capability the model should be free to
increase the amount of latent space used
to represent high density
of the data so as we decode from
Layton's two data the first
transformation before the coupling
layers will consist of a diagonal
scaling matrix s the authors of nice
give the intuition that s is essentially
learning a manifold of the data the
smaller the scaling factor the less
important the latent dimension in the
limit as an element of s approaches 0
the corresponding latent dimension is
effectively removed the overall
objective now consists of summing the
difference between the log probability
of each element of F inverse of X and
the log of the absolute value of the
corresponding scaling factor in s now
even if the model is allowed to dampen
certain dimensions
it might seem pretty limiting to always
have a latent space of equal
dimensionality to the data which is
required for a differentiable by
injection what if we want to explicitly
enforce a small early in dimensionality
well in the paper density estimation
using real MVP a follow-up work to nice
a multi scale architectures use that
allows different sets of latent
variables to correspond to different
resolutions so Leighton's corresponding
to finer details can be optionally left
out during inference now we've
considered a case where we parameterize
a likelihood function as a flow but
they're applicable to other scenarios
where we'd like to form a richer
distribution for example we might
parameterize the approximate posterior
in a VA e with a flow to allow for
better inference so instead of say
restricting the approximate posterior to
be a Gaussian with diagonal covariance
we can use a normalizing flow to
transform this initial distribution and
to something more flexible
we can also view some auto regressive
models as normalizing flows consider a
model that sequentially samples each
pixel on an image conditioned on the
previous ones according to some fixed
ordering if the conditional densities
are gaussians we can view the sampling
noise at each step as a latent variable
this gives us an invertible model we can
obtain a uniquely in factor for an
observation given model parameters now
well that's the evaluation can be easily
paralyzed here the sequential sampling
means we can't generate new examples
efficiently combining this framework
with what are known as inverse auto
regressive flows helps address this so
normalizing flows are neat tool to have
when we'd like to track tably handle
complex probability distributions and we
only touched on a few of the ways of
using them in this video in the
description I've included links for
learning more about normalizing flows in
their origin as well as some recent
papers worth checking out
thanks for watching